antonio senzatella as we noted has had
great success in his career against the
padres a seven and two record and check
this out a 308 earned run average that's
the best he has against any nl west
opponent but at coors field even better
at 261 against san diego historically
one two swung out of miss that's a nice
start 95 mile an hour fastball
and he stayed out of the middle of the
strike zone which is paramount for any
pitcher but particularly for sansa
nelson lamette on the mound tonight for
san diego 28 year old making his third
start
each of the first shoot two innings 29
pitches 30 pitches
here's hampton toppy with wheels at
first he takes off and the throw by nola
is not going to get him
great jump by rymel
so the rockies quickly have a runner in
scoring position
[Music]
this ball out to deep right field myers
back at the wall to make the catch up
against the wall
tapia will tag up and move over to third
base on the long fly out to right field
and hopefully myers is okay
get up against the wall and got his
elbow
pretty good it looks like on the wall
making that catch one out and tapia has
moved over to third base
is charlie blackman
and that'll get the job done
kim throws out blackman charlie's got
his 20th rbi and the rockies truly
manufacture a run a walk a stolen base a
move
a ground ball with the infield back and
it's one nothing home team watching it
from up here but off the bat you know
wait for the exit velocity and the
that's line toward charlie he slides and
makes the catch
now you can't hit it harder than that if
you're tommy fam
and charlie made a very fine play in
right to god
except connor joe
one two pinch
and a swing and a miss so there you go
that's a good slider right there oh yeah
first strikeout for donaldson lumet two
down
here's the one and two reach for and set
in the air shallow right field and trent
christian over to come and get it center
fielder makes the catch that's all for
the rockies in the bottom of the second
first walk handed out by senzutella
loads the bases for san diego
and gives hassan kim a chance senzutela
ready there go the runners the 3-2 pitch
swing and a miss
senza tella keeps the padres off the
scoreboard with a big strikeout
so two down and chronoworth at second
base for manny machado
this one is to deep left field and gone
home run for manny machado his fifth of
the year
a two-run shot that propels the padres
over the rockies it's two to one
some two out magic for the friars
well that was a no doubter
this ball is absolutely crushed it's a
hanging slider
right down the middle
you know that sound
sends shivers
up and down the spines of opposing
pitchers andre's
trying to squeeze another inning
out of miguel diaz here
who has been terrific once again
you don't want to get a letter to
ungrounded sharply to kim he comes up
with it to second for one on to first in
time double play oh hassan kim this game
was in san diego we'd be hanging a star
six to four to three and the inning is
over
looking for more with runners at the
corners and nobody out here in the
visiting half of the sixth inning and
into the game is tyler kinley well he's
a ground ball pitcher about 50 percent
of the time he'll get a grounder 30
years old throws a slide on the fourth
seamer at 95 and a change up enters his
14th game a lot of walks though 10 free
passes austin nola coming up here with
runners at the corners
in the air to center field
hampson back there
will make the catch tagging at third
base is marcano throw will go to third
base and both were able to tag up run
scores padres have a 3-1 lead
so marcano scores on the sac fly fan
moves over to third base
one out another runner
90 feet away from hassan kim
sharply hit to short story's coming home
the tag not there
safe at the plate is tommy pham and the
padres take a 4-1 lead in field wizan
and story tough to get much on that
throw from where he threw it
and fam gets in with a fourth padres run
contact play
contact is made you're off no matter
what
a tremendous play by trevor story and
you're right don from his knees so he
really couldn't get much behind it
foot on home plate before the tag is
applied
and the padres are adding on
but the bases are loaded here
there are two outs the padres have
already added their lead it's four to
one san diego manny to eighth man to bat
this inning hit a two-run homer last
inning
machado sends one out towards right
center field that ball will be
away from the center fielder hampson
and will clear the bases
three runs will score on the triple for
manny machado that puts the padres on
top seven to one
a gapper to right center field for manny
[Applause]
see how nice and easy manny swings at
this ball and lets the bat and his
strength do the work
just out of the reach of hampson what a
great effort he knows he's got to catch
that ball he's got to lay out just out
of his reach everybody's off and running
because it's time to party three and two
bases loaded two outs oh it's a party
all right
pop the corks
there cosmer bats down
440 with two outs and runners in scoring
position you got machado at third
and this one is line to left field a
base hit machado will score and the
padres taking a one lead
[Music]
a six run sixth inning so far for the
padres here is charlie blackman who is
old for three in the ball game tonight
blackman grounds it softly first base
way and late getting over his hill
not in time blackman will beat it out
a little late reaction there from hill
to get off the hill
and acosta well he got in his kitchen
big time snapped the shilay how close is
it
i got out he's got it i got out
absolutely out and the padres are gonna
challenge this
ball is secure yeah he beat him
absolutely
and indeed he is out so the call over
turn padres win it they take game one of
the series big night for manny machado
a five rbi night including a two-run
home run the padres win it 8-1